okay so we are back with extreme carnage
and as i promised you guys uh we're
covering toxin right toxin is gonna be
in here now here's the thing toxin is
the most powerful of all the symbiotes
right i mean the guy's just ridiculously
op and here's the reason why so if you
look at the design of toxin he looks a
lot like a combination of carnage and
venom and the reason for that is carnage
is the offspring of venom and toxin is
the offspring of carnage the important
thing here is that that toxin possesses
powers belonging to both carnage and
venom but he's stronger than both and
the idea was that at the time there was
a desire by carnage to actually kill
toxin because toxin would basically grow
up to become more powerful than
essentially carnage or venom the problem
with this is that neither one was
powerful enough to do it and because of
the fact that that eddie had basically
taken toxin and bonded him to a cop
which in turn would allow toxin to
essentially become a hero it basically
meant that he wasn't really going to be
an evil symbiote similar to carnage or
anything like that and so for a while
toxin was awesome now eventually he was
killed off uh in venom vol 2 and
ultimately he's just kind of just been
around or just sort of been out there
ever since more recently and during this
story in particular the toxin simeon had
actually bonded itself to a kid named
bren who was the son of one of the
basically anti-symbiote task force guys
that worked at alcomax nobody's
significant but toxin had just bonded
itself to the skin the kicker here is
that carnage tries to attain the toxin
symbiote by quite literally bringing it
into the hive but toxin in having any of
that i told you guys toxins on a whole
different level right so when carnage
goes in to try to bring toxin into the
void the mindscape which he pretty much
does toxin just overpowers them right
just like overpowers uh carnage and then
basically destroys carnage in the
mindscape right now carnage in the
physical form isn't is still out there
right but as far as his ability to
access the mindscape it's not there
anymore right this fight happens pretty
fast too like he literally tears the
head off of carnage and is like that's
it right like you know khan just
basically done for and so that's kind of
the crazy thing right that's the power
that toxin has the ability to overpower
carnage in this mindscape and call it a
day now with itself having been bonded
to bran in turn brynn of course shows up
on the scene finds his father injured
and is like okay we gotta go do
something right now at this point you
pick up with hank and you pick up with
flash thompson now again these guys are
working together just because of the
fact that you've got a kind of history
there they both served in the military
they're both looking to to do grander
things and if i'm being honest i think
with hank there's a little bit of i
could do more than what i'm doing right
now not necessarily a kind of uh of hero
syndrome or anything like that but in
the sense that he's kind of like i'm
more capable than what i'm doing at the
moment right he enjoys what he's doing
right working for charitable
organizations and giving the kind of
things they need but being kind of left
out of what you would call the superhero
antics that exist out there kind of
gives them the desire to sort of be
something more and that's why he i
wouldn't go as far as to say he jumped
at the opportunity to work alongside
flash but he kind of did
he really sort of did there but because
of the fact that toxin is by all
standards of measurement a hero he ends
up working alongside uh flash thompson
and silence to try to track down uh
carnage as well as the other life
foundation symbiotes and take those guys
out now at this point we switch over to
a symbiote who depending on who you talk
to can actually be more sadistic than uh
than carnage himself right this is gemma
and gemma is the host of the agony
symbiote now the idea behind gemma being
the host of this symbiote is one she
works for the for the peter crane
campaign basically and that's really
where hank's been tasked as well right
hank it's kind of operating you know
behind the scenes as just what is effect
in effect a normal person that nobody
would really suspect of being a symbiote
operating inside the the peter crane
campaign as well so we can of course
feed information to uh to flash thompson
but the big thing about this is that
gemma would use her powers as the agony
symbiote to basically destroy people who
are predators particularly those who
look who look for and basically assault
women or the defenseless and so when a
couple of guys track her down for the
purpose of doing what you know we could
probably imagine they're going to do she
basically uses the agony symbiote and
takes them out now a big difference here
is the agony symbiote could spew acid
and so that's one of the things that
happens here these guys are just are
destroyed quickly but the more twisted
element of gemma comes into play when
she gets back home and what she actually
does for these people that she kills is
she uses them as trophies right not all
of them just pieces of them like her
lamp the actual uh pole i guess whatever
you want to call it is made of a made of
a human spine she's got an arm mounted
above the tv
right speak no evil hear no evil see no
evil those skulls are kind of sitting on
her on her table so this is kind of the
twisted nature of her now the idea of
agony is she's not really good she's not
really evil she's really just kind of
out for her own ends and that's why when
carnage shows up and basically says hey
like we need to work together then
initially she's kind of like i don't
really do well with a team right i mean
she is technically a life foundation
symbiote but she's like i don't do the
whole team thing i do my own thing but
ultimately a bargain is struck between
her and carnage now we don't know the
details of it we simply just know all
the other members of the life foundation
symbiotes who have been captured have
been brought here right to basically
work alongside uh carnage now the other
caveat to this is that the the initial
task and the initial idea put together
by flash thompson based on everything
that was going on with silence in the
sense that she shut down the uh the
connection of one of the symbiotes to
the hive mind is that she could
presumably do the same thing to carnage
more so than that a way out is a way in
and so if carnage can find them she can
find carnage and so the idea of flash
thompson is go into the void and see if
you can find a way to basically take out
carnage the big kicker to this is that
when she went into the void it was
totally empty carnage wasn't there and
while it was normally a place that was
in effect a reality that carnage could
alter himself right it's basically in
the mindscape of carnage that in turn
with nobody being there that led into
the idea that toxin had destroyed
carnage in the mindscape and toxin was
the only occupant there which is how it
was they kind of met up with toxin in
the first place but the important thing
here is that because of what she's able
to do to kind of communicate and track
down the other symbiotes locate them she
does that right at the behest of eddie
and really of her own desire right she's
not really forced into it it's also
partly her own desire she's able to
manage and basically track down where
the other symbiotes are right where
they're all kind of meeting together and
then carnage basically like references
her right so carnage knows she's there
and he knows they're coming now what
this does is it destroys the element of
surprise which is an important thing and
one of the reasons why is because flash
thompson is not a highly imaginative guy
right he's a cool guy but at the end of
the day flash thompson was just your
standard run-of-the-mill foot soldier he
did learn some really cool elements of
like espionage and things like that when
he was agent venom but in terms of being
able to craft a highly unique plan that
nobody would ever see coming that
doesn't necessarily seem to be the case
but the important thing here is that
because of this bargain that was struck
between uh carnage and agony that
ultimately she ends up siding with
carnage now the important thing here is
that from the perspective of flash
thompson the target is the president of
the united states now the biggest reason
why flash thompson is going with this is
because he's operating under the belief
that the carded symbiote is bonded to
peter crane and whatever motivation the
carnage symbiote happens to have taking
out the president of the united states
would seemingly work now the funny thing
about this is this really falls very
closely to the events of like days of
future past right the funny thing about
this is that while it's not really
referenced here the superhero community
knows about it right it's a well-known
set of events you had mystique and her
brotherhood of evil mutants who tried to
take out charles xavier senator robert
kelly and more mctaggart in the days of
future past timeline they succeeded in
the main marvel universe they were
defeated because of the actions of
rachel summers and kitty pride from the
days of future past universe but the
fact that that was stopped does not stop
anybody from being aware of the fact
that it happened you have to imagine
word spreads right i wouldn't go as far
as to say the flash thompson is like
this is happening and i know it's
they're going to try to take out the
president because it's what mystique did
during days of future past that's not
necessarily the case but it has to on
some level feed into his line of logic
here right the other part of that is it
just makes good sense that if peter
crane is launching a campaign designed
to discredit the president of the united
states and the president's political
party by basically saying all they're
doing here in honor of everybody who
died to kind of make amends for all this
and to do something about this is to
build a statue some meaningless gesture
that has no real uh impact whatsoever
then what we need to do is actually do
something right and so if his campaign's
running in direct opposition to
everything the president's doing what
better way to secure his presidency than
and to really boost his own profile then
to essentially be carnage and then as
carnage kill the president of the united
states which in turn presents the
credibility that alien symbiotes are a
real threat to the earth and then
suddenly you've got peter crane in the
best position as the leader of the
anti-alien movement his profile is
skyrocketed right and this guy becomes
probably the most famous politician in
the entirety of the united states right
so it makes sense this is what they
would do right it makes perfect sense
here the big kicker and the caveat to
this is that as they're kind of
analyzing all this and as they're
looking around that silence comes to the
realization there's no symbiotes here
right there's no one here no one from
the life foundation is here i can't
sense any of them and that's when it
kicks into flash thompson oh my god the
president was never the target it was
never the president that they were going
after like crane is the target right
peter crane is the actual target as soon
as that information is revealed to hank
you basically end up realizing that
gemma of course as we know is agony and
then all the other members of the life
foundation symbiotes are basically there
and they kill hank right they take hank
out just like that only for us to find
out arthur crane the son of peter crane
is the actual host for carnage he's the
one that is possessed by the carnage
symbiote which is a crazy set of events
and so following that you actually get
this insane revelation right you have it
told to flash thompson that of course
hank is basically dead the problem is
that as he's told this this dude is
taken out and hank just comes back and
the reason why is because hank is
possessed by the sleeper symbiote right
and this is the craziest thing here hank
doesn't even know he's possessed by this
guy right and sleeper symbiote this guy
is cool right this guy's one of the
coolest concepts out there in marvel
comics now sleeper is technically a
offspring of venom the big difference
here is that unlike the other offspring
you know carnage and so on it didn't
really bond itself to a host right off
the bat instead it was left in the care
of alcomax but they couldn't bond it to
anybody and they could study it but they
couldn't use it for nefarious purposes
now of course alkamax tried to but in
more recent years you guys are probably
familiar with the sleeper symbiote
because it was it was really accompanied
for a while to dylan brock now initially
it was bonded to him but once dylan's
powers of repelling symbiotes and
controlling symbiotes manifested it
couldn't bond itself to him anymore and
that's why during the events of absolute
carnage and king in black it was
basically a dog that would follow him
around now technically and even in this
moment right now it still lives with
eddie brock and like dylan and them
right it's just here at the moment it's
been recalled by flash thompson and the
reason why is because hank being a
member of the team doesn't really have a
symbiote and so if things popped off it
would basically be flash sending hank
into a death trap and so in order to
ensure that didn't happen he contacted
sleeper and had it secretly bond itself
to hank so that if something like this
happened it would basically heal hank
he'd be able to recover and then alter
his mind so hank would never have any
idea that he was bonded to a symbiote in
the first place so in effect he's asleep
this entire time it's just sleeper
talking to eddie brock
it's really cool and it's very very
ingenious but with them coming to the
realization that the actual target
itself is peter crane the other members
of the life foundation have basically
bailed off after the perceived death of
hank and taken off to the meeting where
peter crane is located and so as he's
out here making this great big huge
speech because the father-son dynamic
proved to be so popular among the
general public and the followers right
because it provided a kind of
wholesomeness right i mean for those of
you guys that are not here in the states
one of the big things that goes on in
the realm of politics is we like to
believe in the idea of like the
wholesome nuclear family that for
whatever reason we still seem to kind of
worship these archaic ideologies in
terms of like how society functions and
in a lot of ways we want our politicians
to kind of follow that right so the
nuclear family the husband the wife the
two kids right that kind of a thing i
mean it's it's silly and nonsensical but
so were american politics but the
important thing here is that the
father-son dynamic resonated right and
so because of that the idea of bringing
arthur out is something that peter does
right he's like arthur come on out here
buddy you know come out here you know
let's you know make your speech and do
the whole thing you know because we're a
father and son we get along when we were
younger we threw the football together
and all that kind of stuff right the
idealized life that so many of the
average people imagine uh is what we
imbue what we body right we're the
perfect family so to speak and
ultimately crane kills his dad
literally because he's possessed by the
carna symbiote he impales his father and
then tears him apart and then basically
while everybody's watching this in
horror that you basically have carnage
who's just like yes right like this this
whole chaos here this whole chaotic
situation the whole thing that peter
crane warned you about this whole
situation that like the future's coming
and there's a you know alien threat
that's going to kill everybody that
future is now now here's a very very
important distinction that we have to
explain here no one knows this is arthur
outside of the members of the life
foundation symbiotes and like flash
thompson and those guys nobody else
knows it's arthur so when you see like
when the general public sees carnage out
here they don't make the connection oh
my god that's arthur crane the son of
peter who's actually an alien and killed
his dad that's crazy no one makes that
connection right and honestly given the
nature of the american people even if we
could we probably wouldn't because it's
not what we would want to believe the
important thing here is the symbiotes
literally just go on like it's a
bloodbath right i mean it's just no
quarters given they kill as many people
as they possibly can and that's the
point that was the whole point here was
to bring peter crane and this this huge
friends of humanity movement together to
organize it to structure it to have him
put on this great big huge display for
the world to see and then turn it into a
veritable bloodbath right now in the
middle of all this of course sleeper
shows up flash thompson shows up silence
shows up right these other members show
up and what you basically have here is a
symbiote civil war right that's
basically what this is carnage and the
life foundation symbiotes or at least
those he could gather facing off against
flash thompson and his symbiotes right
so it really is a civil war in a lot of
ways and it's cool right the symbiote
civil war
it's really cool but of course for the
most part it's a somewhat even battle to
a degree and a lot of this is really
just the result of different symbiotes
having different powers in comparison to
other symbiotes the kind of experiences
they have using their abilities and so
on and so forth the funny thing about
this is that carnage makes this remark
and basically saying arthur crane and
cletus cassidy were in effect cut from
the same cloth sure they're not the
exact same person but their upbringings
are very very similar right that arthur
started with small animals and then he
moved on to homeless people and then he
actually took out a couple of
girlfriends and some different
classmates over the years this guy has a
very very bad history and not only that
at the time that carnage encountered him
he was already in the process of trying
to find a way to take out his dad and
replace him as senator right and so in
effect that's why carnage bonded to
arson now again it does get a little
more significant than that and again
we'll talk about that once we get closer
to the end but in the middle of all this
here comes iron man with his symbiote
slash extremist suit now for those of
you guys who are unfamiliar with this
extremis is is something that's been
around in mobile comics for quite some
time and it was really more of like an
organic iron man suit right that in
years past before extremists iron man's
suits were basically physical armors
right he would step into them like what
you saw with the first iron man movie
the difference between that and
extremist is extremist was more organic
right almost every future version of
armor that he developed was based on
extremist tech so it was very symbiotic
in nature and in truth there wasn't
really any big difference between the
symbiotes themselves and the extremist
tech the only difference is that
extremists was basically nano machines
and the symbiotes are living organisms
but iron man was able to take a symbiote
and bond it to the extremist tech and
then in turn create an extremist
symbiote armor right extreme biot armor
is what he basically calls it and then
in turn go forward from there so he's
basically fighting symbiotes with what
is in effect symbiote combined with his
own tech the big problem here is that
when he's able to blow the carnage
symbiote off of arthur he's like it's
done it's over and then the carnage
symbiote in turn takes over his suit and
then basically bonds itself to his
extremist symbiote armor and then
basically steals it for its own end and
so iron man's literally thrown out of
his own suit is taken over by carnage
and then carnage bonding to this now has
a combination of iron man's extremist
tech and his own symbiote this makes him
highly dangerous because instead of him
just being an organism that can just
bond to people and just do crazy things
now it's one part technology that means
the ability to hack into computer
systems and all kinds of stuff right
like if skynet had a physical form it
would be carnage
that's basically what he is right now
and then he just leaves right he just
like takes off and leaves everybody else
there to basically be captured by by
alkamax and and so on and so forth now
of course the other members of the life
foundation are like what i mean agony
basically ends up taking off with
carnage and that seems to be the bargain
that was struck that no matter how
things played out carnage would
basically take agony with him but
ultimately you know agony ends up
leaving with with carnage they basically
bail out all the other members of the
life foundation symbiotes are rounded up
and captured and that's basically it now
the reason why this matters and the
reason why all this happened with arthur
crane in the first place is because once
it all pops off and it's all over arthur
crane is like like we're like you don't
believe anything that symbiote told you
did you like it wasn't me the symbiote
was lying right like you got to help me
like i don't what's going on here right
like he kind of comes off with this idea
of like i don't know what was going on
and the big thing about this is you
don't know if he's lying or not you
don't know if he's telling the truth or
not now he is ultimately lying in the
sense that what ends up happening is
because of the fact that his father was
killed and his father was a senator of
course whenever a senator basically ends
up leaving office whether it's because
they pass away while in office god
forbid they're taken out while in office
or if they simply have to resign for any
number of reasons it's up to the
governor to to basically appoint a
replacement and the governor appointed
arthur to replace his father as senator
not only that because arthur was viewed
as quote unquote a victim of the entire
symbiote attack during his uh during his
father's rally that now he's the face of
the anti-alien movement basically his
political profile has has been increased
by a huge margin his father died a
martyr and now the whole uh the whole
message and the whole uh you know
philosophy and everything is now left to
arthur right he's a huge deal in the
realm of politics but the way that we
know he's lying is he's ultimately met
by the arrival of agony and he asks her
is there any way to get him back right
bring carnage back to me you know i can
be useful i'll do anything he wants and
she asked the question are you still
useful are you useful to us and he's
like yes i can be right i can be useful
to you guys in reality this is
ultimately what carnage was looking for
now this is one of the things that's
kind of weird here carnage was never a
political character right in the sense
that he got involved in people with you
know in in politics carnage was never
really on that level in fact the events
of absolute carnage had made carnage
more intelligent and more capable than
he'd ever been before and made his
aspirations far more grand than they'd
ever been before the entire basis behind
carnage was rooted in just causing as
much death and destruction as he
possibly could and that was it that was
all it was but that's one of the cool
things about this right the idea of carn
is just killing all kinds of people that
was rooted in the nature of cletus
cassidy bonded to the carnage symbia but
it looks like much like what we've seen
with the venom symbiote and the toxin
symbiotes and all the other symbiotes
carnage has learned carnage has grown
carnage has moved beyond this simple
process of just like i want to destroy
stuff and now his aspirations are going
big time the question is how is it going
to play out and honestly we don't know
but with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end thank you
guys for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace